look I don't know if you're like me but
I hate gems I don't know how to use the
equipment and I feel like everyone there
knows exactly what they're doing except
for me but I feel good when I work out
and I want to feel good about getting a
workout so for the next 30 days you're
gonna be working out at home no gym
memberships no equipment let's see what
happens
[Music]
hey my name is Chandler Graham dad I am
23 years old I am from Toronto Ontario
Canada and I got chosen to be part of
the 30-day home fitness challenge we
audition over 50 people on Instagram and
we selected her for 30 minutes every day
we are going to do a mixture of jumping
jacks flutter kicks mountain climbers
and burpees white Corgi elbas 2018 was
probably one of the hardest years for me
I spent most of the year taking care of
my mom because she was diagnosed with
breast cancer didn't really get time to
focus on myself and I just feel like
it's time for me to get back into this I
have a healthy relationship with fitness
but as far as like actual exercise I do
not feel confident and getting a full
body workout
knowing the moves that I can do to work
different parts of the body let me tell
you something first
I am already a person who works out I
work out in an average of I don't know
three times per week working out every
day finding the strength of the
discipline to do that every day that's
crazy I work really hard to maintain my
weight because I lose it like this and
so to work out every day for 30 days
could drastically change my appearance
than a positive negative weight I just
don't know I shouldn't be scared of
exercise and I shouldn't be intimidated
by it so I'm really hoping this
challenge will make me feel more
confident and capable of exercising in
my daily life beginning
jumping jacks
five sets sortable 20 second rest in
between all right
[Music]
it was really hard for me because I
guess my body just isn't used to that
much activity jumping jacks for fire the
herpes sucked flutter kicks were
difficult and the climbers that climbers
need to be the most challenging thing
for me it's a nice mix of cardio
strength and balance I liked it
Brenda proof I'm doing something wrong
decliners cuz I keep messing up my knee
so you start with the climbers and Jun
slow so that way I don't hurt my knee I
realized I was doing flutter kicks wrong
this whole time and no one told me to do
them right this time it doesn't get
easier they're not easy but they're
doable and that's what's important if
you all wanna thoughts of how much this
sucks it's gonna suck and you're gonna
want it to end but if you're like whoo
yeah that's not good that's doing things
you get reward out of it so I knew going
into this challenge that doing the
exercises for 30 days straight I wasn't
gonna see results unless I changed the
way I was eating put a lot more focus
and attention into the food that I'm
putting in my body I need some
vegetables you're eating more you're
burning more calories I'm feeling extra
hungry
we are halfway through and I cannot
believe that I've made it to this point
yesterday it was a hardest part of the
challenge but it takes a lot of
dedication and willpower and push
through this commit to this and that
dedication of willpower is already
pushing into my day I feel like my
energy levels are way up my sleeping
habits have been amazing I think that my
body is finally adjusting to the workout
I'm definitely seeing some progress
especially on that scale I wish it was
building up like my chest and other
muscles a bit more this is at least
teaching me ways that I can workout at
home base I can feel more confident in
the movements I'm losing a lot of
muscular myths
doing a lot of this cardio the body a
the muscle away my goals have always
been to build up and this is doing the
absolute opposite it was great because
my friends all joined me and I was
really great it was really fun and
motivating and it's been showing me and
Brenda up they're doing this workout
with other people so I'm back in Texas
so I thought what is my sister there's
my sister
I did 30 days of exercise that's insane
I did it I freaking did it I am just so
unbelievably proud of myself if you're
looking for dramatic before and after
photos that's not this video because I
believe that physical transformation and
fitness takes time because everybody's
body is different we did this challenge
so we could feel more confident in
ourselves and in fitness I feel like
I've grown into a completely different
person I my confidence is way up I've
amazed myself my commitment to this
challenge is help me manage some of
those resentful and distressing thoughts
surrounding fitness towards the end he
was always like I hated every second
over the last five minutes but then when
you were at dawn it was like I and while
the goal of this challenge was never to
lose weight for better for worse we lost
some weight I think I lost a little bit
over 10 pounds I lost 9 pounds lost 5
pounds which I need to put back on to
stay healthy we committed to the
challenge and I know that you can commit
to something similar it takes patience
it takes time you can achieve anything
this is to me not the ideal way and
always a chance for you to take it one
step at a time
instead of doing this hoping to have one
Brenda did it Chanda did it I did it and
I know that you can do a workout that
feels good for you this the next
challenge is something I've been trying
to do for 15 years I'm looking for
people who are serious about quitting
smoking but not just cigarettes I kicked
this habit a while ago and I replaced it
with something even more addictive or
placed it with the jewel so if you're 18
years or older and you're serious about
putting the jewel click the link in the
description of audition and go to my
Instagram for more information about the
challenge
let's get better together let's quit the
jewel together let's do this
[Music]